desde el mismísimo instante en el que se
emitió por primera vez bruto tanto en
manga como en su anime he escuchado
críticas sin cesar dirigidas a la serie
que es mala que es sólo una copia mal
hecha de naruto y ahí yo también era de
los que pensaba que bruto era una
completa [ __ ] pero luego de pensarlo
bien y analizarlo detenidamente con mi
enorme cerebro llegué a una conclusión
que me sorprendió y es que todos
estábamos juntando erróneamente a esta
serie bonito no es una mala serie bruto
ni siquiera es una buena serie bruto es
la serie
así que recientemente vi el odio
dirigido hacia la serie y pensé espero
momento esto no está bien pero que las
personas están equivocadas con esta obra
de arte y hoy te lo demostraré
lo que existe
comencemos por lo obvio bruto es una
serie que nadie debe perderse punto full
metal alchemist health inc
sí claro sigue que no que hoy indeed
known and peace dragon ball y nada se
compara a eso
y comenzamos a analizar rápidamente sus
aspectos más criticados como por ejemplo
la cuestión de su historia y el ritmo
que sigue oye pues en el manga está muy
bien si es verdad comenzamos con el pie
izquierdo pero está mejorando pero en el
anime
[Música]
es mil veces mejor no sólo porque el
anime comienza su historia de distinta
manera que el manga cosa que siempre se
agradece sino porque afortunadamente se
nos dio un trillón de capítulos de
relleno con historias supremamente
interesantes que exploran a profundidad
el transfondo de todos los grandes e
interesantes personajes que bruto nos
presentan a lo largo de sus sagas
totalmente originales apartadas de la
verdadera historia contada en el manga
que hablando de eso con estas sagas de
grandioso relleno tenemos un ritmo muy
muy muy lento que funciona perfectamente
sin ningún problema en absoluto este
ritmo lentísimo que tiene la serie
funciona perfectamente para enseñarnos
decenas y decenas de capítulos llenos de
muchísimo diálogo y situaciones
completamente necesarias para entender
el vasto mundo que bruto pone frente a
nuestros ojos como por ejemplo como
hubiéramos sabido que aburrido le gustan
las hamburguesas
los episodios como como hubiéramos
podido ver las supremamente interesantes
y necesarias historias acerca de cada
uno de estos grandiosos personajes que
por cierto podemos tomarnos un tiempo
para apreciar la profundidad el
trasfondo y el gran diseño de los
personajes de borut o tenemos al
todopoderoso burrito a metal y que no se
parece en nada a su padre ni siquiera en
su nombre está kawasaki con su diseño
tan genial y un largo largo etcétera es
decir en alto tenemos personajes buenos
pero aquí mira nuestros diseños para
para cada uno de los personajes que se
nos introducen en la serie transpiran
originalidad por cada poro de su cuerpo
porque quien dijo que los personajes de
bruto son una descarada y ridícula copia
de los de antes vistos en naruto cómo te
atreves míralos míralos muy de cerca en
qué crees que se parecen exacto en nada
son personajes totalmente originales
exquisitamente diseñados con un diseño y
transfondo único e interesante grande
kishimoto y como cereza sobre el pastel
podemos apreciar el debido al respeto
que se le fue otorgado a los personajes
antes vistos en naruto por qué
wow qué demonios pasó aquí
[Música]
además quién fue el que dijo aquella
blasfemia acerca de que solo vemos bruto
porque está relacionada con naruto y no
porque sea una buena serie como tal como
se atreven a decir mentiras como que la
serie solo se pone interesante cuando
aparece alguno de los personajes adultos
como que si no fuera por naruto y sastre
y los demás nadie vería aburrido ya sus
amigos porque son de lo más estúpidos
mentiras como que su serie tiene 300
trillones de capítulos de relleno y lo
único bueno es cuando adaptaron las
novedades o algunas partes del manga
quien fue el que dijo todas esas
mentiras ustedes creen que las personas
ven a burritos lo por su forzada
conexión con la ruta y los demás las
personas no en abortos sólo por naruto y
por sas que coon las personas ven bruto
porque la ser en general es una delicia
es una asombrosa experiencia audiovisual
que nadie debería perderse no lo digo yo
lo hubiese la ciencia volviendo
nuevamente a su historia algo que veo
que a muchas personas les disgusta de la
serie es que todos estos arcos creados
originalmente para la serie son
totalmente innecesarios y no podrían
estar más equivocados es decir claro
disfrutamos las adaptaciones de las
novelas y la saga de monos psíquico
por favor quién quieres la batalla
decisiva entrenar utilizase contra el
monstruo kit como puedes ver unos niños
pidiéndole un autógrafo los imac tenemos
literalmente cientos de capítulos llenos
de sagas interesantes y muy bien hechas
que no nos llevan a ninguna parte como
claro ejemplo tenemos el arco donde
conocemos a innata morada y luego
resulta que la perra está loca trata de
matar a todos y destruir la aldea pero
tú tranquilo que aquí no ha pasado nada
cientos y cientos de capítulos y aún así
se siente como si nunca pasara nada
importante después de todo aún cuando
hayan pasado 150 episodios las personas
aún estaban esperando que boludo
comenzara pero para que avanzar en la
historia si podemos quedarnos otros mil
episodios explorando lo bien que se la
pasa en burrito y sus amigos en la
academia adoptar el manga jajaja eso es
para [ __ ] porque algo que sabemos
todas las personas que ejecutamos esta o
cualquier otra serie es que el relleno
es algo que todos amamos es una verdad
absoluta e innegable y tú lo sabes
podría quedarme horas aquí debatiendo
acerca de todas las cosas que burritos
están extremadamente bien en comparación
a otras series como dragon ball o wampis
para convertirse en rey de los piratas
no me hagas reír nada en este mundo se
compara con querer ser igual
o sí
en fin como decía podría quedarme mucho
tiempo aquí dando miles de argumentos de
por qué la serie de sarthe pero creo que
ya entienden el punto no hay porque hoy
era burrito es decidir si está dañando
el legado de una de las series más
queridas por el público y si tal vez la
serie de haber acabado en este mismo
instante pero debemos estar agradecidos
que en tiempos tan difíciles tenemos
obras maestras como ésta
[Música]
como si estas cosas pasaran
jajaja hablemos en serio unos momentos
antes de terminar el vídeo quieren ya
fuera tarkadas muy todo lo demás no me
gusta bonito la verdad creo que es una
serie totalmente innecesaria y muy
aburrida me le dio todo el manga y es
bastante regular y bueno con su anime
casi ni lo ha visto y lo poco que he
visto pues está feo si es verdad que
existe en el manga es algo intrigante y
de vez en cuando sus batallas y no
masivas son extraordinarias pero la
única razón por la que estoy al tanto de
estas series por su conexión con naruto
y nada más se lo he visto uno que otro
episodio el anime no lo he visto todo y
la verdad no tengo planes de hacerlo
porque la verdad se ve malísima pero aún
así quiero dar el beneficio del agua
burrito me gusta pensar que tal vez en
un futuro la serie puede reunirse tal
vez con el tiempo una serie mejore
[ __ ]
[Música]